[Music]
in parts of ukraine normal people are
now living under russian military
occupation
[Applause]
but despite the might of vladimir
putin's forces protesters are taking to
the streets every day to make themselves
heard
and they're capturing it on their mobile
phones
[Music]
eastern ukraine
a small town of under 10 000 people but
hundreds are out on the streets
residents here had been gathering daily
risking their lives to convey their
message to the occupying troops
but after days of demonstrations
last weekend their chants were met with
violence
[Music]
even as they retreat
the woman filming is defiant
the town's mayor confirmed that nobody
died but said three people were injured
in the shooting and one was beaten
there was a similar scene at a protest
in the southern town of melatopal last
week
but russian soldiers at demonstrations
have largely watched on
and here people continue to take to the
streets
[Music]
they meet daily in the city's victory
square
in this live stream protesters line up
along the road across from the square
[Applause]
the crowd chance go home and later death
to enemies at the russian troops
we see soldiers handing out packages to
a group of people
[Applause]
the streamer says it's all for show the
people they're helping are actors
working for russian tv
pay attention it's still our flag in the
square she says
street demonstrations are now a regular
occurrence in the nearby port city of
berdansk
like melatopal russian troops arrived
here early on in the conflict
but that hasn't dampened the spirit of
the people who lived there
[Music]
in this video taken outside the city
hall in yet nosty square dozens of
protesters crowd a car with the letter
zed painted on it
we don't know who the vehicle belongs to
or why it's there but the letter
originally marked on russian military
vehicles has become a symbol of support
for russia's invasion
the response from the demonstrators is
clear
go home while you're still alive shouts
the man filming
[Music]
scenes like these are playing out in
occupied towns across southern ukraine
every single day
normal civilians congregating in their
thousands making their message clear to
their invaders
victoria elms sky news